Olha só que dado curioso, ou melhor,
preocupante. Perder audição pode
acelerar a perda de memória. Pois é,
segundo pesquisas recentes, quem tem
dificuldade para ouvir acaba exigindo
muito mais esforço do cérebro para
entender sons e palavras. E esse esforço
constante sobrecarrega as áreas ligadas
à memória e atenção e com o tempo pode
acelerar o declínio incognitivo. E tem
mais, a perda auditiva também tende a
isolar a pessoa socialmente, o que
agrava ainda mais o problema. Um estudo
brasileiro que acompanhou mais de 800
pessoas por 8 anos mostrou que quem
tinha perda auditiva teve uma queda mais
rápida nas funções cognitivas. Então
veja bem, se começar a perceber que está
aumentando o volume da TV ou pedindo
para as pessoas repetirem o que dizem,
não ignore. Procureem um torrino ou um
fornodiólogo cedo. Isso pode fazer toda
a diferença para manter a mente afiada
por muito mais tempo.